on a du gras aujourd'hui on en a
beaucoup on a du temps avant d'être à
l'os à ce moment là les choses ont
commencé à devenir vraiment très très
difficile mais pour baisser dans les
premières années première décennies
commencer à s'organiser autrement il y a
vraiment énormément de marge bonjour
Jean-Marc jacovici bonjour bonjour alors
c'est bon bonjour
climatique ne peut plus être nié l'année
2022 a été la plus chaude jamais
enregistrée en France la sécheresse est
déjà là alors que nous ne sommes qu'en
mars l'année dernière les émissions de
CO2 dans le monde ont atteint un nouveau
record le dernier rapport du GIEC publié
lundi alerte une nouvelle fois sur
l'urgence d'agir Jean-Marc jokovici
est-ce que vous avez encore le moral il
y a une je sais pas si on doit dire une
triste nouvelle supplémentaire mais
presque c'est que vous avez alors vu de
Paris un régional de l'étape on va dire
on a appris hier le décès de Claude
Lorius je sais pas si vous en avez parlé
un glaciologue où il y a absolument qui
a été un des une des un des pionniers
une des figures scientifiques en France
qui a fait beaucoup avancer la question
et notamment il est à l'origine enfin
c'est un des personnes qui est à
l'origine de la compréhension du lien
historique entre la quantité de CO2 dans
l'atmosphère et l'évolution des
températures voilà qui est un homme qui
a fait des expéditions en Antarctique et
qui a beaucoup aidé à faire progresser
la science d'où ma question est-ce que
vous avez encore le moral alors vous
savez ça dépend beaucoup du jour de
l'heure de ce qui vous est arrivé juste
avant je reste un animal comme tout le
monde et donc il y a ce que me dit ma
cervel analytique et puis il y a ce que
me disent mes sens et en général tout va
bien quand mes sens me disent que tout
va bien donc je peux très bien avoir le
moral malgré tout ce que vous venez de
raconter et en fait il vaut mieux du
reste garder un peu le moral malgré tout
ce que vous ne racontez parce que sinon
on était tanisé comme le lapin dans les
phares il y en avance pas alors
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on a le moral bah
c'est je vais dire des je suis désolé je
veux dire des banalités désolantes en
général ce qui donne le moral c'est
d'être au sein d'un groupe qui avance
dans une direction qui donne le moral
donc ce qui donne le moral c'est d'être
dans quelque chose de collectif ce qui
donne le le moral c'est d'avoir un but
et ça donne quelque part plus le moral
que les mauvaises nouvelles ne le
détruisent ce qui est terrible face à ce
genre d'information c'est quand on est
seul et des emparés c'est-à-dire un sol
par au sens où on est tout seul tout
seul mais au sens où on peut pas
partager avec d'autres personnes ou sens
où on peut pas contribuer avec d'autres
personnes ils se mettent dans un
mouvement dans lequel on a l'impression
que on commence à prendre les choses en
main voilà alors moi il se trouve que
j'ai la chance de faire un métier qui
tous les jours me conduit dans l'action
face au problème donc quelque part ça ça
donne le moral j'ai la chance d'avoir
des signaux positifs dans les gens que
je fréquente c'est à dire de voir des
gens qui ont envie de commencer à s'y
intéresser mais il m'arrive comme à tout
le monde de temps en temps de me dire on
arrivera jamais etc voilà je ne suis
qu'un être humain
alors les montagnes sont
particulièrement touchées par ce
dérèglement climatique les températures
augmentent plus vite qu'en pleine c'est
plus visible aussi il y a les glaciers
qui font on a eu un hiver compliqué à
cause du manque de neige d'ailleurs vous
avez très bien compris que les Alpes
étaient l'un des lieux propices pour
parler réchauffement climatique puisque
vous avez organisé dans le début des
années 2000 les entretiens de Combloux
vont venir ici pour parler réchauffement
climatique avec des journalistes à quel
point cette région est emblématique
alors je vais peut-être préciser ce que
c'était que les entretiens de Combloux
en fait c'est une initiative que j'avais
montée avec un copain journaliste qui
s'appelle Jean-Louis Caffier parce qu'on
s'était dit que avec des journalistes
mieux formés et en particulier des
dirigeants de rédaction mieux formés on
avait une petite chance qui est un peu
plus d'espace accordée à cette affaire
alors rappelez-vous le début des années
2000 on en est on était à des années
lumière de la prise de conscience
d'aujourd'hui on avait encore énormément
sur les ondes et dans les journaux de ce
qu'on appelle des climato-sceptiques
c'est à dire des gens qui expliquaient
que la science était ni faite ni à faire
et que toute cette histoire c'était des
affabulations on avait énormément de
gens qui n'avaient pas compris alors ça
ça reste encore vrai aujourd'hui le rôle
absolument crucial de l'énergie dans le
monde moderne sans le pétrole il aurait
pas eu le 20e siècle d'accord donc on
serait pas les progrès technique on se
réveille les gens qui nous écoutent ne
feraient pas le métier qui font ils
auraient pas le mode de vie qu'ils ont
ils auraient pas le salaire qu'ils ont
enfin rien de tout ça et le débat sur
les retraites n'aurait pas ressemblé à
celui qu'on a parce que on se serait
écharpé pour savoir si on allait gagner
le dixième ou le 20e donc c'est on
voulait leur faire comprendre ce genre
de choses
et donc et par ailleurs vous êtes bien
placé pour le savoir puisque vous faites
ce métier que tant que vous êtes proche
de votre lieu de travail on vous bloque
pas trois jours pour vous former parce
que au bout de deux heures on va vous
expliquer qu'il y a une urgence que le
pape est mort que je sais pas quoi et
elle craque vous retournez au boulot en
oubliant la promesse que vous avez faite
de rester pendant trois jours à vous
former donc on les a emmenés loin de
Paris nos amis journalistes et on avait
trouvé chez le direct à Combloux le
directeur de l'office du tourisme de
l'époque était un type extraordinaire
qui nous avait sponsorisé intégralement
les deux premières éditions
donc on avait emmené voilà donc on a la
sucette qu'on promettait aujourd'hui
c'était de les emmener dans un endroit
sympathique donc le troisième weekend de
janvier on les emmenait et en fait on
leur faisait des cours on leur disait
pas du tout il faut que vous Spiez le
gouvernement pour ceci pour cela non
c'est pas du tout ça on va leur dire on
va vous expliquer ce que c'est que le
système climatique on va vous expliquer
ce que c'est que du pétrole on etc et
alors je ne sais pas si ça a eu un effet
discriminant ou pas sur le
fonctionnement de la presse française
moi en tout cas ça m'a beaucoup appris
sur la manière dont fonctionne un
journaliste donc ça de mon point de vue
ça a été une très bonne école de
formation voilà donc c'était ça qu'on
était venu faire dans le coin alors
maintenant pour répondre à la question
en quoi est-ce que les Alpes c'est
important enfin exactement la montagne a
un lien important avec le réchauffement
climatique oui vous l'avez dit il y a
des choses qui ne se manifestent qu'en
montagne par exemple à fond de la mer de
glace à Paris c'est un peu compliqué à
observer
il y a également quelque chose que vous
commencez à connaître dans la montagne
qui n'existe pas à Paris qui n'existe
pas en pleine c'est le dégel du
pergélisol et la déstabilisation du sol
à haute altitude et avec le pilier des
druques il y a pas longtemps et il va y
en avoir d'autres malheureusement ça va
continuer ce genre de choses il y a des
modifications qu'on voit sur les
écosystèmes par exemple on voit la
limite supérieure de la forêt gagner en
altitude on voit des espèces remontées
donc les espèces s'étages de façon voilà
l'étagement des espèces remontent
remonte un peu en altitude donc on voit
toutes ces toutes ces choses là j'ai
envie de dire qu'on ne qu'on ne voit pas
en plaine et puis par ailleurs depuis
qu'on a du pétrole la montagne vit du
tourisme parce que avant le pétrole il y
avait pas de tourisme en montagne parce
que le premier déterminant du tourisme
en montagne c'est qu'il faut que les
gens puissent venir
j'ai fait un rapide petit calcul sur
nombre de TGV qu'il faudrait pour
remplacer les voitures qui font le
chasser croisé dans la vallée de la
Tarentaise une semaine de février et je
peux vous dire on y arrivera pas
donc on peut en faire bon courage en
tout cas bah non vous avez quoi 200000
lits dans la vallée de la Tarentaise
dans un TGV vous avez 1500 places donc
vous pouvez faire une règle de trois
vous voyez il faudrait 700 TGV dans la
journée vous allez pas les faire passer
une semaine de février par même pas 700
300 mais peu importe donc vous avez
aussi une bonne partie de l'économie
alpine aujourd'hui qui est basée sur le
fait que les gens et des voitures donc
c'est aussi une question importante on
va dire pour le pour l'économie locale
et puis c'est également basé sur le fait
qu'il y ait de la neige qui tombe
l'hiver j'ai assisté il y a pas très
longtemps à une simulation qui a été
faite sur l’enneigement des pistes de La
Plagne
nage artificiel ou pas et l'évolution
dans les décennies à venir c'est une
question c'est évident je vous apprends
rien
enfin voilà donc il y a un rapport entre
le changement climatique et la montagne
et l'énergie et la montagne d'une
manière générale qui a enfin voilà qui
est particulier il y a un certain nombre
d'éléments qui sont bien bien
distinctifs et qu'il faut prendre en
compte quand on réfléchit à l'avenir
Jean-Marc Janco ici vous restez bien sûr
avec nous on revient juste cette petite
pause Jean-Marc Jancovici est l'invité
de la matinale des super-halifto il a
rien d'action avec Audrey Bordier
toujours avec nous Jean-Marc Janco ici
on parlait tourisme avant avant la pause
à quel point le tourisme les petits
plaisirs de la vie va falloir s'en
priver totalement ou c'est une
transition qui est beaucoup plus lente
il faut espérer qu'on s'en prive pas
complètement en fait aussi loin qu'on
remonte dans le temps il y a toujours eu
quelque chose qui était de l'ordre de du
temps non travaillé on va dire
dans le dans les sociétés humaines ce
temps non travaillé il pouvait être
consacré à des choses qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas du tourisme de la religion ou
des trucs comme ça mais enfin c'était
c'était c'était faire autre chose que le
que le travail
il faut espérer qu'on va en préserver
quelque chose cela étant on
matériellement ce qu'on va faire de
notre temps libre va changer de nature
mais il y a déjà des je sais pas si je
dois dire des pionniers qui aujourd'hui
font les choses de manière un peu
différente alors je vais parler d'une
population que je fréquente souvent dans
le cadre de mon travail dans les jeunes
cas de supérieures ce qui était très
tendance il y a 30 ou 40 ans c'était
prendre l'avion pour courir le monde
maintenant il y a une partie des gens
pour qui ce qui est très tendance c'est
de prendre un vélo d'aller courir
l'Europe bon donc on voit bien que c'est
ils ont toujours du temps libre sauf
qu'ils font autre chose c'est pas
exactement est-ce qu'ils sont plus
malheureux que les gens que pas
nécessairement le bonheur n'est pas
nécessairement proportionnel au nombre
de kilomètres qu'on a fait avant de se
poser quelque part mais c'est sûr que il
va y avoir dans la manière de de enfin
comment dire d'occuper de temps libre il
va y avoir des changements matériels
nécessairement même dans la vie
quotidienne on nous dit il faut éteindre
la lumière faut
utiliser des gobelets pour notre café
même le café est-ce que on pourra encore
est-ce que pour la planète il faut
encore boire du café aujourd'hui il faut
pas nécessairement en boire autant en
fait l'un des inconvénients du café
c'est que quand on augmente la culture
du café on déforest et puis
accessoirement ça vient de loin mais bon
ça le fait que ça vient de loin on peut
faire voyager ça par bateau c'est pas
extrêmement on va dire c'est pas ça a
aimé pas beaucoup
le seul le problème principal comme pour
le cacao du reste ça fait partie de ces
cultures pour lesquelles on prend sur la
forêt pour augmenter les pour augmenter
les plantations alors si on essaye de
regarder où est-ce qu'on a beaucoup de
pression sur l'environnement au travers
de nos actes de consommation il y a
quelque chose qui est un bon outil de
calcul pour ça un bon résumé j'ai envie
de dire c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'empreinte carbone donc l'empreinte
carbone c'est la quantité totale de gaz
à effet de serre qu'il faut émettre
partout pour que vous ayez à la fin un
objet ou un service
donc là par exemple dans ce studio votre
micro il a une empreinte carbone c'est
toutes les émissions qui ont eu lieu
dans tous les dans toutes les industries
du monde depuis la mine jusque au camion
qui est à livrer le micro ici pour que
vous puissiez bénéficier du micro donc
là je parle d'un outil professionnel
mais je pourrais faire la même chose
chez vous avec ce que vous mangez la
fabrication de votre logement votre
voiture etc alors quand on regarde
l'empreinte carbone d'un Français
aujourd'hui vous avez cinq postes qui
sont à peu près du même ordre de
grandeur pas tout à fait mais après du
même ordre de grandeur il y a un poste
qui concerne les déplacements dans les
déplacements ce qui domine de la tête et
les épaules c'est la voiture 80% des
déplacements à domicile travail dans la
région par exemple sont fait en voiture
parce que horrible de France c'est 80%
partout en France
et derrière vous avez l'avion
après vous avez un deuxième gros poste
qui est le logement dans le logement
vous avez une petite partie c'est la
construction enfin une petite partie
c'est une grosse partie quand vous
faites construire mais statistiquement
c'est une petite partie et après vous
avez surtout le confort thermique et le
confort électrique du logement mais
surtout confort thermique donc le gaz et
le fioul qu'on utilise pour se chauffer
ensuite vous avez un troisième poste qui
est l'alimentation dans l'alimentation
le gros morceau c'est la fabrication des
produits animaux donc c'est et en
particulier des produits issus de
l'élevage
ensuite vous avez un quatrième poste
important c'est les achats donc tout ce
que la publicité va promouvoir
donc pas que des trucs alimentaires donc
canapé tape chaise brosse à dents
lunettes enfin voilà tout ce que vous
avez pistolet à eau jeux de société tout
ce que vous pouvez acheter quoi et enfin
vous avez un cinquième poste sur lequel
là pour le coup vous avez très peu de
prise en tant que consommateur c'est les
services publics donc en fait c'est
votre code part dans le fonctionnement
de l'enseignement de l'hôpital de la
police de l'armée etc
là dedans quand vous regardez les
gobelets c'est une toute petite partie
du poste achat la grosse partie du poste
achat ça va être le numérique le digital
les ordinateurs les smartphones les
machins les fringues les meubles
l'électroménager enfin voilà tout un tas
de trucs comme ça les gobelets ok mais
si vous faites juste ça une époque il y
avait une blague vous voyez quelqu'un
qui est dans une usine hyper polluante
qui disait qu'il avait remplacé qu'il
avait fait des gobelets recyclables à la
machine à café bon c'est OK et éteindre
la lumière c'est pareil c'est un petit
geste le gros geste en fait dans la
consommation d'énergie du logement c'est
le chauffage
à quel point dans toutes ces économies à
faire dans ce dans ce bouleversement
notre mode de vie à faire il y a une
part de responsabilité des pouvoirs
publics et des citoyens vous reprenez je
reprends l'exemple de du transport vous
dites c'est le premier poste des
missions en France 80% des gens qui sont
dépendants de leur voiture parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le choix ici les trains sont
très peu développés au quotidien et il y
a très peu de transports en commun à
quel point le citoyen responsable et
pouvoir public on leur parle à faire
alors tout le monde a eu une part de
responsabilité si on prend cette cet
exemple les premiers à avoir une part de
responsabilité c'est les élus locaux
aussi il faut qu'il faut pas oublier
parce que c'est eux qui font les
documents d'urbanisme et c'est eux qui
ont autorisé depuis la fin de la
dernière guerre mondiale ce qu'on
appelle l'étalement urbain c'est à dire
la construction massive d'habitation
dans des endroits dans lesquels de toute
façon vous n'aurez jamais de transport
en commun parce que la densité il y a
une règle dans le monde des transports
en commun qu'on peut citer c'est que à
partir de 100 habitants par hectare à
Paris vous êtes à 150 de mémoire
vous pouvez faire du transport Ferré
à partir de 20 habitants par hectare
vous pouvez faire du bus en dessous vous
faites rien donc à partir du moment où
vous avez fait de l'habitat diffus
pavillonnaire il faut se sortir de la
tête qu'un jour on aura des transports
en commun efficaces pour que ces gens-là
prennent des transports en commun il y
en aura jamais d'accord donc ça veut
dire que l'alternative à la voiture pour
ces gens-là c'est le vélo la marche à
pied permettant et le covoiturage
permettant éventuellement d'aller
jusqu'à un endroit de concentration où
il y aura du bus ou du train d'accord
mais il y aura jamais une garde train de
banlieue ou une gare de TER ou une garde
avec qui va sortir de terre devant le
pavillon au moment où ils ont besoin de
partir au boulot et qui redescendra sous
terre une fois qu'il y a ça n'existera
jamais donc il va falloir s'organiser
autrement et en fait il y a toute une
question qui est posée sur cette habitat
d'issue comment est-ce qu'il survit dans
un monde sans énergie abondante et c'est
une question ou à laquelle et
aujourd'hui les urbanistes auraient
réfléchissent peu les élus locaux encore
moins alors que c'est une question qui
est absolument centrale
donc alors si si on revient la question
plus générale qui est qu'à la part de
responsabilité entre le consommateur les
pouvoirs publics état et les locaux
Europe etc les industriels enfin bon on
va dire que le consommateur peut faire
la moitié du chemin c'est à dire que il
y a une partie de l'abaissement de
l'empreinte carbone qui peut toutes
choses égales par ailleurs ne dépendre
que de vous et là dedans quand on achète
quelque chose on peut faire attention
il y a ce que vous pouvez faire sans
investissement est-ce que vous pouvez
faire avec investissement alors le truc
que vous pouvez faire sans
investissement par exemple c'est changer
votre régime alimentaire ça demande pas
d'investir de manger moins de viande et
plus de pois chiches qui comme chacun
sait et l'aliment de la transition par
excellence par contre ça demande un
investissement de changer votre
chaudière mais c'est toujours quelque
chose qui est à votre main vous n'avez
pas besoin que les pouvoirs publics
fassent quoi que ce soit de particulier
pour changer votre chaudière à fioul par
une pompe à chaleur ou par un poêle à
bois mais c'est mieux la pompe à chaleur
ça fait moins de particules dans la
vallée
pareil pour les moyens de déplacement
vous n'avez pas besoin des pouvoirs
publics pour prendre si vous avez
vraiment besoin d'une voiture la plus
petite possible et non pas la plus
grosse possible ce qui est en général la
façon dont les gens fonctionnent les
gens ont une logique budgétaire ils
s'achètent en général la plus grosse
bagnole qui peuvent s'acheter avec les
contenus des revenus qu'ils ont alors
qu'il faudrait qu'ils disent je vais
acheter la plus petite possible voilà
rien que ça ça fait une différence sur
la consommation vous avez vu l'explosion
des ventes de SUV ces dernières années
ça c'est le consommateur qui a décidé de
le faire il avait quand même pas
vraiment un revolver sur la tempe on lui
a dit tu es obligé de faire ça on l'a
incité gentiment mais il est quand même
et puis il y a d'autres trucs sur
lesquels c'est pas du tout le
consommateur qui a la main par exemple
l'appareil de production électrique dans
le pays c'est pas le consommateur qui a
la main l'organisation des réseaux de
transport c'est pas le consommateur qui
a la main quand vous regardez l'offre de
produits disponibles c'est pas le
consommateur qui a la main donc vous
avez en gros une responsabilité partagée
entre l'offre et la demande la demande
c'est quand même le consommateur l'offre
c'est tous les autres donc c'est le
tissu économique
et les pouvoirs public qui ont également
une un rôle important à jouer dans cette
histoire et puis il y a un rôle
important à jouer aussi sur le discours
global je veux dire le projet de société
relève notamment du discours public
Jean-Marc Jean colesi et notre invité
ingénieur français membre du Haut
Conseil pour le climat fondateur du
shift project on aura l'occasion d'en
parler invité de marque Jean-Marc
Jancovici en disait ingénieur français
membre du Haut Conseil pour le climat
fondateur du shift project on a aussi
j'ai dans ma main si vous êtes avec nous
sur Radio mont-blanc.fr à cette
magnifique BD de l'extérieur mais de
l'intérieur aussi je vous le dis un
monde sans fin on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler Audrey j'en mange encore ici et
notre invité exactement si vous êtes en
train de vous dire c'est quand même
super intéressant ce qu'il est en train
de dire mais j'ai pas eu le temps de
tout noter bien vous allez tout
retrouver dans la dans la BD que tu as
Hugo un monde sans fin best-seller de
l'année dernière je pense que vous
voulez déjà vu dans les bibliothèques de
vos amis de vos collègues etc enfin
c'est vraiment très intéressant pour
avoir une vision globale de tout ce dont
on est en train de parler Jean-Marc
Lancôme ici on parlait avant de la
responsabilité de partager entre les
citoyens entre les fabricants entre les
pouvoirs publics et vous parliez du
discours qui est offert justement aux
citoyens aujourd'hui en France est-ce
que le discours est suffisant non en
fait on a un problème d'incarnation
d'une vision de l'avenir dans l'offre
politique du moment on va dire que une
bonne partie des partis politiques
actuelles il voit l'avenir avec les
règles du jeu du passé donc ils
comprennent pas qu'il va falloir jouer
avec des règles du jeu très différentes
et les gens qui revendiquent sur
l'échiquier politique le fait de voir
l'avenir avec des yeux très différents
c'est-à-dire en gros l'écologie
politique ils ont un cahier des charges
qui reste extrêmement ambivalent et avec
beaucoup de beaucoup d'incohérences
internes donc le aujourd'hui on pourrait
dire que malheureusement non l'offre
politique qui enfin je vais vous donner
un exemple très concret moi à chaque
élection je sais jamais pour qui voter
voilà c'est une autre manière de dire
que l'offre politique pour le moment
elle n'existe pas
et elle est loin d'exister et en fait il
y a un drame dans dans au moins en
France et probablement dans toutes les
démocraties c'est que l'offre politique
elle a toujours quelques quelques années
de retard sur l'état de l'opinion une
blague que je fais souvent c'est de dire
les élus sont un très bon reflet des
électeurs à quelques années de décalage
voilà le temps qui réalise
et puis par ailleurs il faut renvoyer
aux bons auteurs Machiavel déjà il y a
quelques siècles expliquaient que quand
on veut changer les règles du jeu les
premiers qu'on voit débouler c'est ceux
qui vont perdre quelque chose ceux qui
vont gagner ne comprennent pas encore
qu'ils vont gagner ils ne comprennent
pas encore ce qu'ils vont gagner puisque
c'est le futur etc et donc vous les
voyez pas débouler dans votre bureau en
disant donc il y a une asymétrie on va
dire dans les gens que vous avez en face
et après on reste tous des êtres humains
ordinaires donc quand vous avez surtout
à faire à des gens qui viennent
expliquer que ça va pas vous avez pas de
tendance à être extrêmement courageuse
donc c'est c'est une voilà donc il y a
un vrai un vrai sujet
d'incarnation de ce de cette affaire là
dans le monde politique et puis par
ailleurs il y a un autre problème dans
le monde politique c'est que dès que
vous défendez quelque chose de
particulier
vous n'arrivez jamais à faire consensus
parce que le jeu des autres est toujours
de vous dézinguer pour expliquer en quoi
ce que vous proposez c'est moins bien
que ce que vous proposez vous donc le
genre de sujet que je porte c'est
difficile d'en faire des sujets
consensuels dans le monde politique
parce que dès que
une personne d'un parti s'en empare en
fait le jeu normal c'est tous les autres
explique qu'il raconte des bêtises il ou
elle donc c'est voilà donc c'est c'est
difficile de de faire rentrer ça et
pourtant ça serait éminemment nécessaire
parce que on a vraiment besoin d'un
projet structuré pour avancer
pendant que votre antenne était occupée
par des publicités on avait une petite
discussion interne ici avec la question
qui qui était de savoir comment est-ce
que on arrive à avoir des
objets
[Musique]
c'est pas grave j'ai perdu le fil de ma
pensée en direct
tout le monde fait ça de temps en temps
donc voilà donc il y a un vrai sujet il
y a un vrai sujet sur l'incarnation sur
l'incarnation de dans dans le monde
politique qui est difficile à mettre en
place alors que pourtant ça sera
évidemment nécessaire pourtant Jean-Marc
jeancourci il y a les cops tous les ans
il y a les accords de Paris qui ont été
en 2015 on s'est dit ça y est enfin ça
va bouger il y a quelque chose qui va se
créer pendant l'impression que derrière
ça c'est essoufflé alors la COP elle
porte l'illusion qui a un maître du
monde mais il y a pas de maître du monde
en fait la COP c'est une assemblée
onusienne les assemblées onusiennes sont
des assemblées ou tous des sites par
consensus et quand on est dans une
assemblée où tous décide par consensus
en fait vous ne pouvez rien faire
d'autre que d'entériner ce que les gens
sont déjà prêt à faire donc en fait les
cops entérinent ce que les États sont
déjà prêts à faire pour des raisons
domestiques et aujourd'hui ils sont pas
prêts à faire grand-chose donc c'est
pour ça que les cops sont toujours très
des ventes parce que en fait elle
matérialise le fait que pour des raisons
domestiques les états n'avancent pas
vite j'en mange j'en trouve ici vous
dites l'un des problèmes centraux de de
tout ce dont on est en train de parler
c'est le fait que les pays se base
uniquement sur la croissance sur le PIB
il y a qu'un seul indicateur qui vaut
c'est le PIB
depuis qu'on vit dans un monde facile on
va dire donc depuis l'avènement de
l'énergie abondante on a eu tendance à
considérer que en fait quel que soit la
taille de l'économie tout le reste de
l'environnement n'allait pas bouger dit
qu'est-ce que c'est que le PIB en fait
le PIB c'est chez désolé des termes un
peu technique c'est la somme des valeurs
des objets disponibles à la consommation
finale donc la consommation finale c'est
les individus un petit peu les
administrations et souhait donc c'est
tout ce que les individus achètent à la
fin on va dire donc des poireaux des
frigos des casques enfin tout ce qu'on
veut et plus le PIB augmente plus ça
veut dire que la valeur totale de ce que
nous consommateurs finaux on a augmente
donc on a de plus en plus de trucs de
machins et de services en gros et avec
la manière dont l'économie est conçue on
ne compte pas la destruction des actifs
naturels qui va en face du fait d'avoir
de plus en plus de choses chez nous et
dans notre environnement donc plus le
PIB augmente plus à nous donne
l'impression que avec ces indicateurs
qu'on manipule qu'on va avoir de plus en
plus de choses tout en continuant à
avoir la neige qui tombe les montagnes
des espèces vivantes les rivières qui
etc donc tant qu'on a cette vision là du
on va dire de notre rapport au monde
c'est normal qu'on souhaite la
croissance parce qu'on se dit on a de
plus en plus de trucs et on n'a pas les
inconvénients voilà alors cet indicateur
enfin l'économie l'indicateur économique
est devenu quelque chose de plus en plus
important au cours des 19e et 20e siècle
et donc aujourd'hui c'est là dessus que
on porte tous nos efforts avant toute
chose c'est clair que on va devoir en
sortir et on va devoir en sortir pour
une raison au moins c'est que le système
économique qu'il a besoin de ressources
naturelles pour fonctionner et que ce
soit pour des raisons environnementales
ou que ce soit pour des raisons de
diminution des stocks de toute façon des
ressources naturelles il y a un moment
où on va en avoir de moins en moins et
en fait en Europe on a déjà commencé à
rentrer dans cette dynamique ce qui est
une autre manière de dire que toute
façon en Europe on est déjà rentré dans
une dynamique où le PIB vrai par
personne il a déjà plutôt tendance à
baisser si on regarde par exemple en
France le revenu disponible déménages il
baisse depuis 2010 donc ça fait plus de
10 entiers et la raison à la base elle
est physique c'est pas parce que on a
des politiques qui s'y prennent
n'importe comment c'est peut-être vrai
aussi il paraît peut-être n'importe
comment pour réagir à cette contrainte
mais par contre la contrainte de base
elle est physique depuis 2008 qui est
l'année où la production mondiale de
pétrole dit conventionnel c'est-à-dire
ce qui est pas le shaila et américain le
pétrole de schiste américain et ce qui
n'est pas les sables bitumineux
canadiens en 2008 cette production est
passée par un maximum depuis
l'approvisionnement énergétique de
l'Europe baisse de manière subie et
depuis cette époque l'Europe est entrée
dans une forme de récession larvée si on
regarde ce qui est physique par exemple
les mètres carrés qu'on construit dans
l'année par exemple les tonnes qu'on
charge dans les camions c'est des
indicateurs qui baissent depuis cette
année-là et donc le revenu disponible
des ménages baisse depuis peu après
cette année-là et malheureusement ou
heureusement je ne sais pas ça va
continuer c'est c'est une tendance c'est
une tendance lourde pour des raisons
pour des raisons physiques
à partir du moment où vous avez un
indicateur qui se met à évoluer dans le
mauvais sens de façon subie il vaut
mieux arrêter de le regarder parce que
sinon vous êtes très malheureux moi si
je regarde si si à l'âge que j'ai le
seul indicateur qui compte c'est la
vitesse à laquelle je cours j'ai pas
intérêt à regarder ça tous les jours
parce que je vais assez rapidement
mettre à déprimer donc il vaut mieux que
je me mets que je me mette à regarder
autre chose voilà c'est exactement
pareil il va falloir qu'on arrive
collectivement à se sortir de cette
obsession pour l'accroissement de la
consommation matérielle parce que sinon
on va probablement se condamner à être
extrêmement malheureux alors c'est un
sacré défi ce que je suis en train de
dire parce que pour donner un exemple
parmi d'autres qui a peut-être faire
sauter en l'air un certain nombre de
gens qui m'écoutent ça veut dire par
exemple que dans les entreprises on ne
considère pas la revendication salariale
comme étant le truc le plus important
qui soit bon courage bon courage mais
mais voilà c'est c'est un exemple
concret
qui peut incarner ce que je suis en
train de raconter voilà et il faut pas
qu'on se dise ouais c'est facile pour
lui parce que c'est pas c'est c'est
ça va être comme ça à un moment que va
se poser problème alors il y a un mot
qui fait peur et d'ailleurs vous vous
l'avez pas évoqué mais vous en parler en
sous-tex c'est le terme décroissance
vous dites c'est pas une question de
savoir si on veut ou pas la décroissance
et savoir c'est de façon elle va arriver
vaut mieux vaut mieux se préparer alors
c'est ce que je viens de dire à
l'instant en fait elle est déjà là si
vous regardez sur des indicateurs
physiques elle est déjà là et en fait ça
va continuer c'est c'est obligatoire
pour des raisons pour des raisons
physiques il y a plein de décroissances
qui sont déjà là aussi regarder le
nombre d'espèces elle est déjà là la
décroissance si vous regardez les
insectes elle est déjà là la
décroissance si vous regardez les arbres
qui se portent bien en France elle est
déjà la décroissance donc il faut pas
croire que c'est un truc pour l'avenir
si vous regardez la taille de la Mer de
Glace elle est déjà la décroissance donc
la décroissance physique elle a déjà
commencé sur un certain nombre
d'indicateurs et en fait le fait que
économiquement on est l'impression qu'il
continue à y avoir de la croissance
c'est pour partie des artefacts
comptables en fait cette croissance elle
est essentiellement sur les actifs
immatériels d'une partie des gens qui se
portent bien je parlais tout à l'heure
du revenu disponible des ménages sur le
revenu de l'essentiel des Français la
décroissance est déjà là aussi donc
c'est pas pour plus tard la décroissance
elle a déjà commencé dans le pays sur un
certain nombre d'indicateurs et je le
redis il va falloir s'organiser avec ça
donc ce qui veut dire qu'aujourd'hui à
chaque fois qu'on fait un plan pour
l'avenir que ce soit les entreprises que
ce soit la puissance publique etc il
faut vérifier donc moi je dis pas qu'il
faut souhaiter ou pas la décroissance je
suis même pas là à ce stade il y a des
gens qui disent c'est souhaitable moi je
à ce stade j'évite même ce débat parce
qu'il n'est pas nécessaire pour ce que
je vais dire derrière il est essentiel
de se dire imaginons que ce soit le cas
est-ce que mon plan il flotte toujours
voilà et donc moi j'invite vraiment les
dirigeants d'entreprises les élus locaux
les élus régionaux à se poser la
question en disant est-ce que dans ce
contexte là mon plan il flotte toujours
parce que si la réponse est non et ben
on prend un sacré risque
comment est-ce qu'on continue à avoir
notre train de vie ou peut-être un petit
peu moins dans mais en tout cas la vie
qu'on a aujourd'hui très industrialisée
très tertiaire avec beaucoup de bien
notre service avec énormément de confort
dans la vie de tous les jours tout en
justement renversant la balance pour que
ça ne soit plus au détriment de la
planète pour que les ressources ne
soient plus authentiques on est
tellement au-dessus de ce qui est
nécessaire à un certain nombre de choses
qui nous rendent heureux que on a du
gras alors je vais donner quelques
exemples on se déplace aujourd'hui dans
des voitures qui font en moyenne une
tonne et demi
quand j'ai appris à conduire moi j'ai
appris à conduire dans une deux chevaux
qui faisait 500 kg bon alors certes je
suis très très vieux mais quand même je
donc je pense que avant d'être
malheureux parce qu'on a plus de voiture
du tout
on parlait pas plus tard que ce matin on
peut peut-être revenir à des voitures
qui bon l'essentiel du temps notre
voiture elle roule à moins de 110 ou à
moins de 100 km/h bah vous faites des
voitures électriques de 500 kg qui
roulent à 100 km/h est-ce que on va tous
se flinguer à cause de ça je ne suis pas
sûr
prenez l'alimentation aujourd'hui dans
l'alimentation l'essentiel de la dépense
alimentaire qu'on se c'est des produits
transformés c'est du sucre c'est des
sodas vous savez quels sont les
premières références vendues dans la
grande distribution c'est de l'eau en
bouteille qui vaut 1000 fois plus cher
au litre que l'eau au robinet et qui est
pas de meilleure qualité même s'il est
même s'il a publicité nous fait croire
que c'est un médicament non en fait
c'est voilà on vous intoxique pas avec
le robinet et c'est des sodas c'est à
dire des trucs qui vous collent le
diabète et bon donc je pense que si on
s'en passe on sera pas nécessairement
beaucoup plus malheureux en fait la
seule question que ça pose c'est les
gens qui fabriquent de l'eau en
bouteille et des sodas qu'est-ce qu'on
leur fait faire voilà c'est ça la vraie
question
une mutation de la société c'est ça la
vraie question mais dans l'entreprise
qui est juste à côté si on passe de
pièces pour l'automobile à des pièces
pour vélo ils ont même genre de problème
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des gens qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des machines qu'est-ce qu'on
veut comment est-ce que on trouve des
nouveaux clients donc les une partie des
entreprises vont avoir ce problème il
faut les aider il faut pas refuser
l'évolution toute façon il va y avoir
droit donc il faut mais nous en tant que
consommateur encore une fois du gras on
en a énormément je vais prendre un autre
exemple on est là maintenant à 3 mois de
Noël enfin Noël est passé depuis 3 mois
regarde la quantité de jouets qu'on
offre à nos gamins qui servent une fois
0 fois deux fois et qui après dorment
dans un placard bon des fois c'est le
carton qui est plus utilisé que que
on leur offrirait que des cartons je
serai ravis donc n'en fait des choses
avec des cartons et bien le ces jouets
on les aurait pas fabriqués est-ce que
les gamins auraient été considérablement
plus malheureux je ne suis pas sûr voilà
donc on a du gras aujourd'hui on en a
beaucoup on a du temps avant d'être à
l'os à ce moment-là les choses ont
commencé à devenir vraiment très très
difficile mais pour baisser dans les
premières années première décennies
commencer à s'organiser autrement il y a
vraiment énormément de marge
donc
ici d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
sur du Mont Blanc je rappelle donc que
vous êtes ingénieur spécialiste du
climat vous êtes fondateur du shift
Project vous êtes le co-auteur de cette
BD que Hugo nous a montré tout à l'heure
un monde sans fin qui est toujours en
tête de gondole de vos pharmacies de vos
pharmacies de vos livres préférés oui
oui c'est un médicament on pourrait dire
et si je lis la quatrième c'est la fin
du monde Jean-Marc idéalement pas tout
de suite sur la page Facebook de radio
Mont-Blanc et sur Radio mont-blanc.fr